good morning hickets tuesday i saw
everybody's comments about my
magnificent 2021 vision board so many
people said for instance that we should
not manifest a cat sequel how do you
think we got into this mess
not via poor political leadership or
failing to recognize that viruses are
uninterested in political borders we got
into this mess
because we started 2020 with a cats
movie and the only way we're getting out
of it is with
another cats movie i also stand by all
the other goals in this vision board
like i do need to finish my book of
extremely in-depth yelp reviews that
comes out later this year and i do want
to get the vaccine into my arm and i do
intend to keep afc wimbledon in the
third tier of english football by sheer
force of will and i do want to spend
less time staring into the abyss
sorry what were you talking about right
my vision board i also saw how over at
reddit user atlas gray whiteboarded my
whiteboard so now anyone can do anything
they want with it
a power that ritz 37 used to put me in a
turtles all the way down situation and
smh matrix used to make my 2021 vision
board my past mustachioed self
and oh that's great hank i want people
to have fun with my vision board but
what they don't know is that 2021 is the
year of
the vision board specifically the year
where i update my vision board
every single week except for some weeks
when i might be out of town or filming
on location or something
what i'm getting at hank is that there
are going to be a lot more vision boards
around here not least because
using dry erase board in more videos was
part of last week's vision board
so what's on the board this week first
review lemmings this one is fairly
self-explanatory provided that you know
i'm a semi-professional reviewer of the
anthropocene and also a person who is
interested in lemmings
then we've got micro capsules so the
reason scratch and sniff stickers work
is the same reason time released
medication works is the same reason
triplicate forms work they all use a
technology called micro encapsulation
which i need to better understand
for the anthropocene reviewed book what
else is going on this week we also have
manifest birds with arms this one is
also fairly self-explanatory it's all
that birds are missing another bird
related one convince geese to migrate
so every year more canada geese become
permanent non-migratory residents of
indiana even though that pond is of no
use to you
all you have is the memory of that being
water now it's just
a rock and it will be a rock for months
so
fly south and give me a few hours
without your incessant honking okay what
else we have sign name
ten thousand times so to make sure that
every copy of the first printing of the
us edition of the anthropocene reviewed
book is signed i have to sign about ten
thousand times per week this is around
like 600
so yeah it's fairly straightforward i
just have to sign each
one of these sheets then we've got read
books not tweets
when i read annie dillard on eclipses or
terry tempest williams on erosion or
even
extremely upsetting books like paul
farmers fever feuds and diamonds about
the history of sierra leone and our
response to ebola i don't feel
calm exactly but it does make me feel
informed and engaged without
experiencing the sour sweet dopamine
rush seasoned with panic that i get from
twitter
there is a lot more of course because
this year demands nothing if not
visioning
hank i'll see you on friday